lara à table
attaque je te dis
les mâles ce qu'on avait voilà
encore d'aknoul c'est pas de nous céder
linguine sait ce que ça veut dire liquid
en italien les petites langues
allez mange
moi moi moi les coupes
c'est con mais mangent en italie
et je salue ma princesse tu peux me remy
thouars s'il te plait bien sûr non plus
viens d'un petit chaperon rouge
il était une fois une petite fille la
plus jolie conçu voir sa mère en était
folle première chose sera fait leur
bonheur le loup les 7 chevaux un jour
dans un pays ont atteint une vieille
chèvres qui avait sept chevreaux et qui
les aimait comme chaque mère aime ses
enfants complètement la regarde la
princesse au petit pois c'est bien il
était une fois un prince qui voulait
épouser une princesse mais une vraie
princesse
il fit le tour de la terre pour en
trouver une
mais il y avait toujours quelque chose
qui clochait les princesses il n'en
manquait pas mais était peut-être des
vraies princesses
papa ouais chatel très fort moi aussi je
t'aime très fort cet automate oui maman
vous l'amener à la danseuse arrête de
t'inquiéter comme ça ça va on se
débrouille très bien tous les deux ouais
ouais j'ai prenez la maîtresse atteinte
en voiture ok bon bah je t'embrasse mois
corner
message supprimé n'avait pas du tout les
sages savez un message d'archivés pour
le consulter tapie lagarde a même encore
je me prépare je ne fais pas de tous les
âges vous avez un message par chim le me
suis dit
vous